you know what i think this conversation
deserves what some of your wine okay
you know
i think
i think that we should have a drink
cheers
so
this is actually your wine so any woman
that makes wine is a friend of mine so
what what led you to this venture my
girlfriend and i catherine power um oh
we didn't um we didn't know what's in
our wine you know we didn't know what
was in it um sorry that was my first
taste that was really
yeah that was my first day it's supposed
to be good yeah um it's uh you know we
didn't know what was in our wine because
it's not disclosed there's no labeling
on wine it's one of the only consumables
that doesn't have an ingredient list and
so we kind of took a deep dive into
winemaking and found that there are um a
plethora yeah
of um additives that can be utilized in
the wine making process for various
different reasons yeah that's why i
don't feel that on french wine they
don't do those attitudes well our
roses are french okay and so is our red
not even
spanish and yeah it's really delicious
it is um and we did cans because you
know we advocate moderation at avalene
we're not a party you know you don't
want anybody holding someone's hair you
know exactly not at all yeah you know
and you know sometimes you go to the you
know you want to go to dinner and this
fits perfectly in a fanny pack i will
say
not that i've heard from a friend you
know
going to catch her on a hike she's like
hold a minute you know
when i go to dinner with a girlfriend
who's i know is not going to be having a
glass of wine and i want to just have a
glass of wine i pop one of these into my
bag and yeah i just have i get the
perfect serving it's not more than i you
know would drink on my own i like it
yeah yeah yeah all right cheers cheers
it's really nice yeah
so
this is amazing i don't drink after
people oh i haven't drank oh you have it
well don't drink after me i won't
because i know what it tastes like i
don't need to drink it
normally okay i was afraid to do this
because normally i don't like white wine
that's good everybody says that about
our white wine they i normally don't
like don't drink like white lime okay
now i look like that girl at the party
i'll go right here on kelly i'll hold
your hair
it's been a rough two years camera
no so i love this video we found this so
here you are sharing a can with a friend
yeah
which is an amazing friend i just love
that y'all
you've you've got to see the whole video
because i this is my question one have
you ever dressed up from something about
marrying have you ever done that for
like halloween or nothing no of course
not that would be the greatest thing
actually i totally told um benny benny
drama if you guys know him on instagram
he's so hilarious he's like a genius him
and his um his partner terry we asked
them to do something with us with avalyn
and um
and they came up with this idea yeah and
i was like you guys are just too funny i
know like you're just too funny i just
the upsetting for people watching though
is that you look identical to what you
did in the world before and i'm like
that door opened and i was like
i was like
i can't say that on the show but i was
just like damn
[Music]